joyeux anniversaire mon amour les choses
ne vont pas bien entre nous et j'en suis
désolé
je sais que cette surprise ne réglera
pas tout en un clin d'oeil je t'aime de
tout mon coeur
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare
[Musique]
je suis impressionné qu'il soit arrivé
jusque là
j'ai une dernière surprise
ne s'ennuiera pas tant qu'on n'aura pas
ouvert le coffre
deux cent mille dollars joli diament on
se partage de diamant allons-y il ya
deux personnes qui connaissent la
combinaison du coffre le gars qui nous a
engagés et la fille elle doit être à des
kilomètres maintenant
elle est toujours dans la maison
[Musique]
plus personne ne sera blessé
ils veulent que tu crées
piti piti piti
anniversaire il faut
le couple parfait
je vais me couper la main pour me
libérer toi s'il me reste pas d'autres
solutions